le programme des fusées sondes est
suspendu jusqu'à l'organisation d'un
événement majeur l'Année géophysique
internationale récemment l'idée d'une
année internationale géophysique a été
lancée par plus de 60 nations effort
scientifique à l'échelon mondial en vue
de faire progresser notre découverte du
monde planétaire et de l'infini ces
hommes de science et leur gouvernement
respectifs décidèrent de se livrer
pendant la durée de l'Année géophysique
internationale à de nouvelles recherches
scientifiques pour le bénéfice de la
communauté mondiale ça c'est un contexte
qui a joue un rôle important avec comme
objectif de de faire une étude globale
de la terre et nouveauté de faire une
étude à la verticale donc d'explorer
toute la haute atmosphère la BAN lieu
terrestre c'était un grand projet et
c'est à l'occasion de cet événement
scientifique mondial que la course à
l'espace a réellement commencé à la
surprise générale les Soviétiques
devanceent les Américains le 4 octobre
1957 le célèbre bip bip du satellite
sputnque raisonne dans le monde entier
la France avec un peu de retard va elle
aussi participer à cette année
géophysique elle souhaite en effet
accéder à la haute atmosphère pour
réaliser ses propres expériences le
programme véronique est alors ressuscité
avec dès le début la contestation de la
classe scientifique qui craint que le
budget engagé pour le développement des
fusées empiète fortement sur celui des
expériences une Véronique améliorée et
mise au point plus fiable plus puissante
ce sera la véronique dite agi pour année
géophysique internationale toute une
série de ces fusées est développé pour
être opérationnelle dans les premiers
mois de
1959 on s'est trouvé avec donc un
programme français spatial qui
comportait 15 fusées véroniques
c'est-à-dire des fusées sondes qui
devaient monter à 200 km enortant une
centaine de kilos qui n'avait encore
jamais été tiré et qui pourtant ne
portait rien on savait pas quoi faire si
la France se démène pour mettre au point
ses fusées sonondes Véronique elle ne
maîtrise pourtant pas encore à l'époque
les instruments qui permettent de rest
depuis le sol les mesures effectué en
vol par les outils embarqués ce qu'on
appelle la télémesure cette lacune
limite donc les possibilités
d'expérience scientifique à placer dans
les véroniques agi il faut alors trouver
une solution pour faire taire les
contestataires et c'est le jeune
chercheur Jacques BLAMON qui va suggérer
une idée très simple il recommande
d'utiliser les fusées en s'inspirant
d'expérien américaine il va proposer de
disperser du sodium dans la haute
atmosphère pour en observer et mesurer
le comportement une expérience originale
qui ne nécessite pas de
télémesure je prétendais ça a
effectivement été réalisé que on pouvait
mesurer un paramètre très important et
pourtant inconnu la température de
l'atmosphère dans la tête de la fusée
les savants ont installé leurs appareils
de mesure et une charge de sodium qui
sera éjectée dans la haute atmosphère un
des arguments que j'avais donné pour
l'emploi des nuages de sodium c'est que
ça se verrait ça se voyait à 1000 km les
trois premiers tirs de Véronique agi
réalisés en mars 1959 seront consacrés à
cette expérience ils vont permettre à
Jacques Blamont de faire une découverte
scientifique sensationnelle qui va
ouvrir la voie des expériences
scientifiques françaises dans la haute
atmosphère Jacques Blamont découvre une
limite de l'atmosphère qui sera appelée
turbopaose c'est bien simple vous avez
un nuage de sodium c'est-à-dire une
traînée qui suit la trajectoire de la
fusée ça commence à marcher quand il y a
plus beaucoup d'oxygène donc au-dessus
de 100 km alors cette traînée elle se
trouve dans le le milieu où il y a des
vents les vents la poussent et donc on
voit cette traîné se déformer très
fortement alors de cette déformations
vous déduisez l'existence d'une série de
mouvements dans la haute atmosphère qui
apparaissent à partir la stratosphère et
qui sont très importants donc vous
décrivez la physique la dynamique de
votre atmosphère de cette manière-là qui
était inconnu mais en plus il se trouve
que quand vous voyez les photos du nuage
de sodium et bien vous voyez que
au-dessus de 100 km le nuage est très
lisse au-dessous de 100 km aussi bien la
montée qu' la descente il est globuleux